except graciously so I recently went to
an internet cafe because I had a big
problem I had this meeting that was
coming up and my internet had gone down
before on them and I didn't want the
internet to go down again when I had
this meeting so I thought I'm gonna go
to her internet cafe make sure that I
have solid internet I won't have any
problems then J reyez friend of the
channel suggested I go to a place near
him and he introduced me to the his
friend that ran the place let's call him
Marty Marty was great give us everything
we needed we were there for two hours
each he charged us way less than he
normally would because of his friendship
with Jay rise and best of all the call
that I had with my client went really
well the internet was stable no issues
everything was fantastic when I was
leaving I wanted to show my appreciation
to Marty wanted to really thank him for
the help that he gave me you know this
was an important business day for me and
the fact that he charged me eight
dollars or something just wasn't
anywhere close to the value that I
received he wasn't willing to take more
money and so I said you know what you've
got these snacks behind the counter
here's twenty bucks give me twenty
dollars worth of snacks and i'll give
them to j reyez to eat to thank him too
for making that introduction and he said
no and he said no because he felt like I
didn't need to do that for him because
he felt like he just wanted to provide
great service and I think a lot of
entrepreneurs you might fall to the same
chop you might fall into the trap of of
trying to over-deliver on service which
I totally agree with but you're cheating
your customers an opportunity to feel
good about themselves to for me given
the twenty dollars to Marty made me feel
good right it made me feel like I could
appreciate him in another way and it
also would make J reyez feel good
because he's get some extra snacks to
leave home with and and you don't feel
his belly with and so everybody loses in
this scenario here is Marty thinking
that he's doing everybody a favor
meanwhile I don't get the satisfaction
be able to do something good for him
I don't get the satisfaction of J reyez
having some snacks J reyez doesn't get
the satisfaction of having things in his
belly and being happy too and so this
was a potential win-win-win where Marty
collapsed it and turned it into
something that only he's winning that
and I want you to understand the
difference because when people offer
help you don't always have to feel like
you could do everything yourself you
don't always have to be the person
giving and buy them giving to you it
makes them feel good too it's not all
about you and so the next time that you
have an opportunity to accept graciously
are encouraged you to take it and stop
staying in your head and think about by
them helping you they're getting value
as well thank you guys so much for
watching I'd love to know in the
comments a story that you guys might
have about accepting graciously whether
you have accepted something from
somebody else or refuse to accept
something share it in the comments below
I'm really curious to find out and I'm
going to join in the discussion thank
you so much for watching continue to
believe and I'll see you soon